so there was a lesson plan that just
popped up from virginia this is a third
grade
lesson plan from the virginia state
education website
which
glorifies communism virginia department
of education
has third graders learning that police
hate black men they have them watch a
video that seems to glorify communism
the lesson first of all the lesson plan
is just written with typos which
at the most basic level shows you the
state of american education but it's
it's provided for use by any teacher in
the state the lesson plan which is very
uh
radical on gender theory very radical on
racial theory and explicitly marxist and
anti-american
the lesson plan was developed
by chesapeake public school teachers
their names are candace anthony
kazanov jamie marquis
they they have children especially
focusing on this this book a is for
activist a radical leftist book has no
place in the classroom so what should
happen here
what should happen
i think there are three schools of
thought there's the leftist school of
thought which is yes that's right that's
what education's about
it's not about teaching kids facts
it's not about teaching them how to
think
in a critical way that's reasoned and
based on logic no it's about turning
them into activists to fight the system
even though we're the system by the way
the it's about turning them into
radicals who are going to end depression
so that's the leftist view right this is
all great this is basically all that
they should be learning in schools
then there is the kind of squish view
with this is the view of the
conservatives for the past 10 15 years
which is well you know this isn't that's
not good that's been so okay they can
read their radical gender racial theory
in the classroom i don't want it
academic freedom i don't want to tell
them they can't but maybe could they
also possibly read a history book or
something maybe please right so that's
the the squish academic freedom view
then there is the conservative view
this is trash
this is harming children's education
this is harming the children's
understanding of the world
it should be banned from the classroom
and the teachers behind it should be
fired
simple enough a teacher doesn't have a
right to go teach
nazism in the classroom a teacher
shouldn't have the right to teach
communism in the classroom
simple and i'm not saying teach about
nazism or communism that's why of course
they should teach about these things
but they shouldn't be able to teach
through this lens of ideology they
shouldn't be able to teach you yes
nazism is good hitler's awesome you
should all
goose march and zig isle
likewise they should not teach you
communism is good the tenets of
communism are wonderful and you should
all become communist activists fire them
academic freedom to quote william f
buckley jr as mainstream a conservative
as ever there was founded the postwar
conservative movement
he said academic freedom is a hoax it's
a farce it's never used
to justify teaching things that are more
conservative or right-wing
it's only ever used as an excuse to
teach your little kid that your little
boy that is a little girl or to teach
white kids that they're evil or to teach
you every child in america is a rotten
and terrible place and to teach them all
that communism's terrific
fire them fire them ban it from the
classroom some people get it again in
florida they're actually doing a pretty
good job at this
other republican politicians need to
follow suit i'm so glad you liked that
video i hope you check out the whole
episode it's available here on youtube
but more importantly than that
it's available at apple podcast spotify
google play stitcher wherever you get
your podcast subscribe to the michael
knoll show i really really appreciate it
sort of helps us circumvent some of the
big tech sensors out there i'll leave a
five-star review if you wouldn't mind
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you